[Music]
yo man
yo open up man yo what you want man my
constituents just caught me
you let them catch you i don't know how
i let this happen
wait where the place next door you know
wait i thought you ordered all the
restaurants to close man i don't know
what to do
just say it wasn't you all right voter
came in and they call me red handed
eating at the place next door were there
a lot of people there
picture this it was not that vacant like
a hundred peeps or more
how could i forget that i had vandal
gatherings just a prime example
of a really big hypocrisy you don't
understand we're not like other
creatures
rules do not apply to us we are the
leaders voters can't be trusted to be
indoor eaters
they are more contagious after all their
mouth breathers just tell them it's
important to follow all the law
how any violation might kill a grandma
while you do what you want even pardon
in-laws
mr mayor how would you prefer your foie
gras donate it
so we saw you at a party it wasn't me
eating at the french laundry
it wasn't me you even had the clam
chowder it wasn't me
sir we got you on camera it wasn't me
you said we can't be super spreading
it wasn't me so i missed my brother's
wedding it wasn't me you jailed a barber
for hairdressing
i have a wedding this is getting
upsetting
butter came in and they got me
red-handed eating at the place next door